bilan de plus en plus tragique en inde à
la suite d'une fuite de gaz toxique à
bhopal dans le centre du pays
12 100 morts au moins des centaines
d'autres victimes condamnées qui
nouvelle calédonie edgard pisani
consulte à nouméa à paris débat à
l'assemblée nationale consensus sur le
principe de l'autodétermination mais pas
sur le processus accord à dublin pour
réduire la production de vin en europe
les négociations sur l'entrée de
l'espagne et du portugal dans le marché
commun seront donc poursuivis selon le
calendrier prévu
claude cheysson qui craint le quai
d'orsay en janvier prochain pour la
commission de bruxelles c'est ce qu'a
annoncé à dublin le président me taire
détournement d'avion au meurtrier sur
téhéran quatre palestiniens abattent un
et peut-être deux des 150 passagers d'un
airbus qu est madame monsieur bonsoir il
s'agit bien de la plus grande
catastrophe écologique jamais survenus
dans notre civilisation industrielle en
inde le quart de la population de bhopal
la petite capitale de l'état du madhya
pradesh dans le centre du pays
le quart de sa population souffre
affreusement de la fuite d'un gaz
toxique survenue hier dans une usine
appartenant au groupe américain union
carbide le dernier bilan officieux fait
état d'au moins 12 cents morts et il
s'alourdit d'heure en heure douze mille
personnes s'entassent dans les hôpitaux
et beaucoup d'entre elles sont sans
doute condamné des images extrêmement
pénible isabelle bessler ils sont morts
comme des mouches asphyxiés dans leur
sommeil ou terrassé par le gaz sur les
routes alors qu'il tentait de fuir
désespérément les environs de lusine
meurtrière ils sont morts étouffés par
un oedème pulmonaire dans des
convulsions atroce et de revendeurs en
dénombre deux nouveaux cadavres
les vieillards et les enfants ont été
foudroyées les premiers par le pesticide
les autorités de l'état de maria pradesh
ne recensait que 475 mort mais la morgue
est pleine et déjà le bois lui destiné
au bûcher hindous traditionnelle vient à
manquer à bhopal vingt mille personnes
au moins ont été exposés à l'isocyanate
de méthyle 2000 d'entre elle agonise
dans les pires souffrances les autres
les plus solides arrivent par centaines
dans les hôpitaux de fortune agitaient
de tous et de nausées aveugle ou les
épures élan on a réquisitionné tous les
étudiants en médecine des environs mais
les moyens sont insuffisants pour
soigner les plus gravement atteints il
faudrait autant d'unités de réanimation
que de malades pendant qu'on s'affaire
avec l'énergie du désespoir dans les
hôpitaux l'angoissé trains ceux qui
n'ont pas pris la route de l'exode
ils attendent des nouvelles des leurs
mais le danger n'est pas écarté car le
nuage de fiqh plane toujours comme la
mort sur la ville l'air est trop humide
pour qu'il se dispersent l'usiné d'union
carbide a cessé sa production et cinq de
ses responsables sont en prison mais
dans le bidonville voisins c'est la
désolation
oui des scènes d'horreur vraiment des
scènes d'horreur qui vont se poursuivre
pendant plusieurs jours encore l' usine
de pesticides de bhopal autour de
laquelle vous l'avez vu s'étaient
agglutinés les bidonvilles sept usines
produisent et de l'isocyanate de méthyle
ce gaz mortel dont une union carbide a
décidé d'arrêter la production dans le
monde entier les fabriquer on n'est pas
fabriqué en france mais il ya un centre
de stockage près de béziers où les dents
de sécurité sont infiniment plus
strictes qu'elles ne l'étaient
semble-t-il en inde
jacques violet l'isocyanate de méthyle
est en quelque sorte la matière première
qui sert à la fabrication des pesticides
et désherbants utilisés pour
l'agriculture
le réservoir qui a explosé hier matin à
l'usiné de bhopal contenait 45 tonnes de
ce produit très volatile très
inflammable et très toxique qui a des
effets analogues à des gaz de combat
seulement deux usines au monde fabrique
ce dangereux
produits celle de bhopal en inde causes
de la catastrophe et une autre aux états
unis dans une conférence de presse la
compagnie union carbide propriétaire de
ses deux usines décidé dès hier
d'arrêter toute production
mais s'il n'est plus fabriqué ce produit
continue d'être stockée et utilisée pour
la fabrication des pesticides notamment
dans une usine en france à côté de
béziers le matières premières arrivent
des états unis donc du lieu de
production par bateau à fos et ensuite
arrive à béziers par transport terrestre
quelles sont les mesures de sécurité à
béziers dans une usine comme celle ci
alors du fait d'une manière générale si
vous voulez en france on n'a pas eu de
grands accidents depuis faisait en 1966
ceci dit il y à des mesures permanentes
de sûreté et de sécurité sur la
prévention technique qui doivent être
mises en oeuvre dans le cadre du
contrôle qu'exerce l'état au travers de
l'inspection des installations classées
et qui concerne précisément l'ensemble
de ces sites dangereux s'il est moins
présent dans les pays occidentaux où la
sécurité est plus grande
le risque d'accident reste permanent
dans tous les grands complexes
industriels
la situation nouvelle calédonie continue
de nourrir le débat politique à paris et
sur le terrain la tension reste toujours
aussi vive le délégué du gouvernement et
deux gars pisani est arrivé ce matin à
nouméa
il a aussitôt entrepris ses
consultations avec les dirigeants
politiques locaux
mais avant d'engager le dialogue les
indépendantistes du front de libération
kanak socialiste exige toujours la
libération de quinze prisonniers
politiques
quelques heures après monsieur pisani
une délégation de la commission de
contrôle du sénat conduite par l'ancien
ministre rpr yvon bourges est arrivé de
son côté à nouméa
à paris l'assemblée nationale s'est
réuni ce matin pour entendre une
nouvelle déclaration du premier ministre
sur la situation dans l'archipel
laurent fabius a lancé un appel à la
raison et à la trêve politique
politicienne
dans le débat qui a suivi les orateurs
des différentes formations politiques
ont exprimé un accord de principe sur
l'autodétermination mais de profondes
divergences sur le processus
la suggestion la plus originale est
venue du socialiste lionel jospin qui
propose une indépendance pluriethnique
daniel brême et jean-louis le sait le
débat ce matin était sans passion la
gravité de la situation en
nouvelle-calédonie freinait les
débordements d'où l'appel de laurent
fabius à la trêve politicienne sur ce
sujet pour le premier ministre
ton apaisant mais ferme on ne peut comme
le souhaitent certains faire comme si
les indépendantistes n'existait pas on
ne peut pas non plus comme le disent
d'autres faire comme si les européens
n'existait pas c'est à partir de ces
réalités qui sont contradictoires qu'il
faut frayer un chemin par
l'autodétermination et qui sera
précisément l'avenir de la nouvelle
calédonie sous les yeux de dit que web
pierre messmer accepte
l'autodétermination mais par n'importe
comment
donc le procureur
lorsqu'on discute sur un pied d'égalité
avec un pseudo gouvernement illégal ami
du colonel kadhafi je doute que vos
négociations aboutissent à rétablir la
paix civile
vous créez et c'est aussi un sujet
d'inquiétude vous créé sur un territoire
de la république
un dangereux précédent qui risque d'être
invoquée ailleurs et plus brève
pour le parti communiste attention à
l'engrenage coloniale dont de méfiance
il faut reconnaître lucidement les
droits historiques du peuple kanak sur
cette terre il faut reconnaître ses
droits a dirigé ses affaires a décidé de
son sort librement y compris s'il doit
s'agir demain de la dépendance sur les
bancs du df ton critique et interrogatif
quelle sera désormais la mission des
trois mille hommes sous les armes
ils sont sur place vont ils devoir
accepter de nouvelles humiliations
enfin pour le parti socialiste ton
professoral
on cherche des solutions
ne faut-il pas que les membres tous les
membres de ces communautés caldoches et
kanaks ainsi défini vote c'est mes votes
séparés j'avance mes propres solutions
messieurs dans sa réponse aux orateurs
laurent fabius a redit sa volonté de
voir une nouvelle calédonie retrouver le
calme une ligne de conduite horde et
dialogues je m'y tiendrai sans faiblesse
at il annoncé
ton de premier ministre réaction du
secrétaire général du rpr à la
proposition des lionel jospin un vote
séparé des deux communautés serait
inconstitutionnelle et instituerait une
sorte d'apartheid selon jacques toubon
du dr jean claude gaudin est plus dure
encore il s'agit d'une magouille
électorale dont le ps a le secret at il
dit dans l'île les barrages érigés par
les kanaks et aussi par les caldoches
entravent toujours la circulation et
entretiennent la tension tio sur la côte
est resté encerclé les gendarmes
enfermé au nord de l'île où se sont
rendus jean-michel mercure orléans
régalé la population européenne est à
bout de nerfs
à l'arrivée ici dans le nord ce sont un
peu des images d'exode qui nous
attendent
des vieux des malades des mères et des
enfants qui embarquent pour être évacué
sur nouméa
il n'y a pas que des missions militaires
d'évacuation et de ravitaillement chaque
jour des particuliers de font
bénévolement
là où c'est possible avec des avions
privés une situation qui dure et qui
excède la communauté blanche des
broussard ont terrifié ici et là leurs
propres barrages
depuis plusieurs jours ils contrôlent
eux mêmes les voitures pour y chercher
des armes
ils sont décidés et s'organisent pour
échanger des informations à l'aide de
l'acide sans vraiment vraiment sur les
nerfs ou dépressifs look et moi qui suis
métropolitain je suis oreilles
j'ai connu ici pour faire la guerre mais
si au moment où on me dit oui tout ce
que j'ai amené ici moi j'ai remis ici de
l'argent pour pouvoir faire j'ai
travaillé j'ai défriché ouvre alors on
se défendra jusqu'au et croyez moi s'il
ya du retour à nouméa
les civils évacués ont voyagé avec des
gardes mobiles qui viennent d'être
relevée en brousse
les européens ne décolère pas ils ont le
sentiment que les forces de l'ordre ne
font pas leur travail ou sont mal
utilisés on a vraiment l'impression
qu'on est en train de nous larguer
bassement et alors je vous le dis je
vous le répète moi je ne suis qu'un
petit ouvrier qui a tout investi cbi en
calédonie quelques heures à peine avant
l'arrivée des gardes j'ai mis sur les
territoires les violences continuelles
de nuit à quelques kilomètres de nîmes
et à de blanc s'était blessé par balle
devant un barrage indépendante et les
dix chefs d'état et de gouvernement
européens réunis à dublin depuis hier se
sont mis d'accord sur les moyens de
limiter la production de vin dans la
communauté
le sommet s'est terminé ce soir cet
acord dublin devrait permettre de
poursuivre comme prévu les négociations
sur l'entrée de l'espagne et du portugal
sur place à dublin
philippe sassier et le matin les dix
avaient le sourire
il savait déjà qu'un accord sur le vin
est pratiquement acquis et que la
volonté politique l'emporter sur les
querelles technique cet de volonté
d'avancer
le président de la république et le
chancelier d'allemagne l'umq illustré à
l'heure du petit déjeuner où ils ont
trouvé en buvant leur café un accord sur
le sucre âge du vin allemand l'allemagne
a accepté de faire un effort pour
contrôler davantage sa production
mais le véritable enjeu est de réduire
la capacité de production de 20 en
europe et la bettino craxi le premier
ministre italien s'était montrée jusqu'à
dublin
très réticent à des mesures de
discipline rigoureuse pour la france la
maîtrise de la production
la priorité à donner à la qualité sur la
quantité et le redressement des prix du
vin était indispensable avant
d'accueillir dans la famille européenne
et l'espagne qui est le propriétaire du
plus grand vignoble mondial
l'accord de dublin qui va pénaliser ceux
qui augmenteront leur production ils
rechercheront pas accroître le rendement
de leur vignoble a une signification
clair la production de vin ne peut plus
progresser
pour le président de la république
l'accord sur le vin est valable et les
intérêts des viticulteurs français sont
sauvegardés on a décrit comme obstacle
principal le problème du vin or le
problème du vin est réglé je fais l'idée
centrale et vous avez compris était
l'arrivée de l'espagne dans le marché
commun
ne devait pas correspondre à une poussée
de plantation de production espagnole
qui pouvaient déséquilibre est
complètement un marché déjà fragile en
europe
il fallait donc une imitation de
production déjà l'europe produit trop de
vin et la réforme du marché mise au
point à dublin 20 stores et un système
de limitation de la production et de la
distillation
les explications de jean marc dubois le
but de cet accord entre les dix d'abord
réduire la production des vins table en
europe
une production qui en 84 aura coûté plus
de 7 milliards de francs dette du fonds
européen agricole ensuite relevé les
prix du marché qui sont aujourd'hui
extrêmement bas pour y arriver les dix
ont choisi deux mesures principales
imposées en début de récolte une
distillation obligatoire à très bas prix
pour faire correspondre les quantités
produites et les besoins des
consommateurs
autre mesure poursuivre la politique d'
aide à l'arrachage et éviter de
nouvelles plantations en kata fraction
des sanctions financières sont prévues
un accord qui ne surprend pas les
viticulteurs du midi le midi viticole se
sommes ce soir plutôt sacrifier que
plutôt content pourtant ça a l'air
d'être un bon accord non ce n'est pas un
bon accord je crois que le seul point
sur lequel nous positionne être d'accord
avec ce qui est sorti du bled c'est la
destination obligatoire à bas prix nous
l'avons toujours dit nous sommes pour
une distillation qui dissuade certaines
parties de l'europe à produire des
veines d'une qualité douteuse
par contre il ne veut n'y en a dans
aucun doute qu'une ligne
une référence à une garantie de prix
pour les volumes commercialisés
donc pour nous ce ne peut pas être mon
accord le problème maintenant est de
savoir si les 10 bientôt les douze se
donneront les moyens suffisants pour que
cet accord soit réellement appliquée à
madrid ce soir on juge très positif
l'accord intervenu à dublin
confirmation à dublin le ministre des
relations extérieures claude cheysson
est nommé commissaire européen à
bruxelles le président mitterrand vient
de l'annoncer à la clôture du sommet
européen
le monsieur besson ne quittera pas
immédiatement le gouvernement
remaniement ministériel limité devrait
intervenir d'ici janvier prochain et
l'on s'attend à ce que roland dumas
jusqu'ici ministre des affaires
européennes et porte parole du
gouvernement
succède à claude cheysson au quai
d'orsay paul nahon coach et son cours de
ces trois ans a passé beaucoup plus de
temps à l'étranger qu'au quai d'orsay
cependant la politique étrangère est
toujours du domaine réservé du président
de la république et clochers sont en a
été le brillant exécutant le
rapprochement avec les états unis la
bataille des pershing louis du
gouvernement français pour
l'installation des fusées américaines
sur le sol européen
le liban l'envoi du contingent français
son retrait l'europe et sa relance au
dernier sommet de fontainebleau cheysson
le gaffeur sans doute mais peut-on
appeler cas des prévisions qui se sont
toujours révélées exactes
rappelez-vous le jour de la mort de
sadate claude cheysson avait prédit que
les gîtes reviendrait peu à peu au sein
du monde arabe
c'est le cas aujourd'hui ou encore
pendant les événements de pologne
il avait affirmé que l'occident ne
ferait rien l'occident n'a rien fait
pour les son retour n'avoir donc à
bruxelles bruxelles où il avait déjà été
pendant huit ans de 73 à 80 le
commissaire chargé du développement en
corse l'ex flnc a diffusé un communiqué
aujourd'hui un communiqué qui ne
revendique pas les attentats de ces
derniers jours mais qui les lie à la
situation coloniale fait au peuple corse
selon l'expression utilisée dans ce
texte qui affirme si la nouvelle
calédonie appartient aux kanaks la corse
appartient aux corses fin de citation à
bastia un millier de personnes ont
manifesté cet après-midi à l'appel de la
cgt sur place dominique quers première
manifestation aujourd'hui après la
fusillade de bastia où un jeune crs a
été tué halte au terrorisme à la
violence affiche les organisateurs du
défilé
seule la fen a répondu à l'appel de la
cgt 4 à 500 personnes marché en silence
cet après midi en direction de la
préfecture d'ajaccio
mais ce matin au nom de l'assemblée
régionale jean paul de rocca s'est
rappelé lui aussi à une grande
manifestation jeudi à l'heure où sera
inhumé stéphane guillon le crs a battu
après une minute de silence le président
de l'assemblée demande à tous les corses
de s'unir pour lutter contre la violence
la séance s'achève avec la marseillaise
pendant que les élus nationalistes et
autonomistes quitte la salle
mobilisation syndicale et politique
alors que la nuit dernière de
gendarmerie ont été mitraillés sans
faire de victime
et qu'une charge de plastique a explosé
à bastia devant le cabinet d'un avocat
mobilisation policière des barrages ont
été mis en place toute la nuit
les enquêteurs ont trouvé dans un fossé
une 4l qui pourrait être celle qui a
servi à l'attentât
ce matin un communiqué du flnc est
parvenue aux différentes rédactions de
lille il ne revendique pas clairement
les attentats de ces derniers jours mais
affirme que les événements de dimanche
sont à mettre à l'actif de la situation
coloniale en corse
le président de l'assemblée régionale
corses appellent la population à
manifester jeudi au moment où se
dérouleront à 3 les obsèques du crs tué
dimanche à bastia l'autre crs grièvement
blessé ce soit en mars est dans un état
satisfaisant
une vieille dame trouvée morte cet après
midi à paris dans le 18ème
arrondissement est aussitôt rhône et la
psychose du ou des tueurs qui entre le 4
octobre et le 12 novembre dernier dans
le même quartier de paris ont tassé ciné
9 femmes toutes âgées
pourtant les enquêteurs ne font pas le
lien avec les précédents assassinat
hervé bougies elle gardait son petit
hôtel nuit et jour
lazare insee riez avait 95 ans cet
après-midi des clients ont entendu des
bruits suspects dans la cour madame
sérieuse agoniser avant de mourir elle a
pu dire mais qu les deux hommes des
cagoules
ce soir les enquêteurs n'ont rien voulu
déclarer sur les circonstances de cette
mort une bombe lacrymogène a pourtant
été retrouvés sur les lieux
est-ce la cause du décès de madame
sérieuse ou la vieille dame lath elle au
contraire utiliser contre ses agresseurs
dans le quartier on la savait
effectivement très énergique
non oui il paraît qu'elle laissait un
peu la porte ouverte je vous propose
elle avait déjà été agressé pourquoi
apparemment il s'agirait donc d'une
agression de plus sans rapport avec les
neuf femmes assassinées entre octobre et
novembre derniers l'accroissement du
nombre des policiers dans 18e n'a
visiblement pas dit suède dissuader les
malfrats du quartier les deux hommes
sont en fuite
vive émotion chez les taxis parisiens
après l'assassinât de l'un des leurs
hier soir à nanterre le cidunati réclame
un renforcement des contrôles de police
nouveau détournement d'avion sur
l'aéroport de téhéran ce matin
détournement tragique quatre pirates de
l'air qui se disent palestiniens ont
détourné un airbus des lignes aériennes
koweïtienne qui assurait les liaisons
entre dubai et karachi à bord 150
passagers et 11 membres d'équipage un
passager a été tué peut-être un deuxième
françoise champeaux une seule certitude
un otage a déjà été exécutée 10h30 ce
matin l'un des 150 passagers est amené à
la porte de l'avion un revolver braqué
sur la nuque
un pirate tir à bout portant puis
précipite le corps dans le vide
tout en continuant à faire feu au cours
de la même fusillade
un deuxième passage est atteint il
serait mort des suites de ses blessures
ce soir 23 enfants et 20 femmes ont été
libérées selon l'une d'elles
les pirates au nombre de quatre seraient
d'origine palestinienne
le détournement a été revendiquée à
beyrouth par l'organisation du 17
septembre date des massacres de sabra et
chatila les pirates chercherait à
obtenir la libération de condamnés à
mort jugés responsables des attentats de
décembre 83 ou au koweit
à l'heure qu'il est les pirates menacent
d'exécuter un otage tous les quarts
d'heure en échange de la libération des
femmes et des enfants
les autorités iraniennes ont ce soit
accepté de ravitailler les avions en
carburant attentats palestiniens
bucarest ce matin le numéro deux dans de
l'ambassade de jordanie a été tué en
plein centre de la capitale roumaine son
agresseur palestiniens été arrêtés le
plus prestigieux des journaux français
est en crise ouverte la société des
rédacteurs du monde société qui détient
une partie du capital du journal a
rejeté hier soir le plan du directeur
gérant andré laurens pour tenter de
résorber le déficit financier de journal
andré laurens a décidé de démissionner
serge me serais était cet après midi rue
des italiens
laurence a démissionné en un clin d'oeil
la nouvelle a fait le tour de la maison
ce sont ses confrères journalistes de la
société des rédacteurs qui l'ont mise en
minorité
refusons son plan de redressement depuis
andré laurens s'est enfermé dans son
bureau
refusant les interviews il restera en
fonction jusqu'à son remplacement
je crois qu'on devrait laurence en tire
les conclusions il pensait que le
redressement de l'entreprise et le
redéploiement de l'entreprise passer par
un certain nombre de mesures de
réorganisation de la fabrication de la
politique des salaires et de la vente de
l'immeuble
l'actionnaire principal dit que ça ne le
convainc pas je ne pense pas que ce soit
la bonne méthode
le gérant en tire les conclusions et va
passer la main mais voilà lors de
nouveau en crise le sentiment que vous
êtes certaine manière victimes de la
démocratie que vous êtes à vous même
imposé disons que
oui je ne sais pas si nous sommes
victimes mais c'est vrai qu'on éprouve
du mal à gérer notre entreprise avec nos
méthodes démocratiques le monde connaît
depuis plusieurs années un certain
nombre de difficultés perte de lecteurs
qui l'ont amené un déficit de 70
millions de francs
la vente de l'immeuble a donc été
proposé presque en même temps le journal
connaissait la première greffe de toute
son histoire
tout cela dans un climat extrêmement
tendu le projet de diminuer les salaires
de 14% n'a pas arrangé les choses
le vote des journalistes c'est d'abord
le désaveu d'une politique c'est
vraiment un acte de méfiance et un
dangereux comme ça de changer de cheval
au milieu du gué c'est toujours
dangereux sur le cheval que ce soit au
milieu du gué ou ailleurs mais la coupe
reste un gay moi c'est plutôt pro -
alcool un col il faut le passer
s'ils ont le passeport on tombe
et si on y parvient on débouche sur la
plaine club de là pour nous nous n'avons
pas le choix
vous avez voté contre le plan ou contre
monsieur lawrence
c'était très liés c'est un vote de
confiance donc contre la politique et
contrôleur voilà ça fait le 20 décembre
prochain l'assemblée générale des
actionnaires devrait en principe
soumettre à l'approbation de la société
des rédacteurs le nom du ou des nouveaux
gérants c'est de nouveau le flou une
chose est sûre c'est que la guerre de
succession va recommencer pour la
première fois dans l'histoire du journal
il est question de faire appel à une
personnalité extérieure au moins des
changements dans notre rédaction albert
du roy devient directeur de la rédaction
d'antenne 2 à la place de michel
toulouse et henry en simple devient son
adjoint
par ailleurs le président de la société
jean claude hébert l'est a annoncé que
la télévision du matin sur un thème 2
commencera le 7 janvier prochain après
la carotte de la publicité coups de
bâton pour les radios locales en tout
cas à paris la haute autorité de
l'audiovisuel a pour la première fois
décidé de suspendre les autorisations
d'émettre qui avait été accordé à 6
radio locale parisienne et non des
moindres
puisqu'il s'agit entre autres des deux
radios locales les plus écoutées à paris
énergie et 95 2 les radios sont décidés
à continuer à émettre depuis neuf jours
l'américain william schröder vie dans un
hôpital de louisville dans le kentucky
avec un coeur artificiel son état de
santé s'améliore de façon spectaculaire
et il a même pu s'entretenir dimanche
devant les caméras avec son chirurgien
lui six boules alors aucune douleur
aucune gêne particulière williams
renault se sent parfaitement bien et
fait preuve d'un moral à toute épreuve
c'est comme si j'avais de nouveau 40 ans
confie style j'ai l'impression que je
pouvais sortir aller à la pêche
regardez les matchs de foot 3 quand il
est rentré à l'hôpital
il savait qu'il ne lui restait plus
qu'un mois à vivre il se sentait le plus
en plus faible mais depuis la
transplantation du coeur artificiel
c'est comme s'il avait encore au moins
dix ans à cela ce qui lui permet de
tenir le coup son optimisme garder le
moral haut niveau tout le monde avait le
moral je retire tout marcherait bien
mieux et son médecin renchérit 6 ou les
malades étaient comme l'entretien s'est
terminé par des félicitations mutuelle
vous êtes formidables docteur at il
conclu et vous donne un mot de sport
avec la première course transatlantique
espagnol qui a démarré dimanche dernier
le catamaran de philippe poupon a pris
la tête de la course us devant
charente-maritime et et royal les
concurrents de tête sont au large de
rabat par tout petit vent et puis en
guise de conclusion presque ces images
qui prouvent que nos moeurs même sur un
plateau de télévision sont bien plus
paisible que celle des hollandais à
débat en direct a eu lieu hier soir sur
une chaîne de télévision hollandaise
un débat entre adversaires et partisans
du régime en place au surinam l'ancien
guyane hollandaise et participants vous
voyez en sont venus aux mains ou plutôt
au point un coup de feu a même été tiré
bilan deux blessés et trois arrestations
dans le pays que des cartes célébrer à
juste titre pour sa tolérance
alain gillot-pétré en reste tout pantois
et pourtant il va nous parler du temps
du dialogue en météo dialogue entre
l'est et l'ouest regardez la photo de
cet epic sont d'une part un anticyclone
sur l'est de l'europe et l'anticyclone
des açores
les deux vont se rencontrer à laroque
voyez c'est un vrai dialogue sans coût
sans rien simplement cette dépression
qui va en faire les frais puisque l up
elle va être heureux je trie justement
ce à la longue ça va les calmer regardez
là après dissipation des brumes et
brouillards
ce sera du beau temps des
pyrénées-orientales aux cévennes aux
alpes et à la méditerranée chauffe
encore sous les averses persisteront
attention brouillard persistant aussi de
la franche comté à la lorraine ou vosges
et à l'alsace sur le reste du pays
après dissipation du brouillard quelques
éclaircies beaucoup de passages nuageux
et simplement des bruines sur les côtes
de la manche le baromètre est en hausse
thermo être aussi de 4 à 13 degrés sur
la moitié nord 10 dans la capitale et de
8 à 16 degrés sur la moitié sud on a
gagné un petit degré à toulouse à
biarritz en corse à nîmes et à perpignan
demain c'est le maître 10 5 décembre
minutes de soleil au moelleux 8h27
coucher 16h55 bonne fête à tous les
virages à 23h15 c'est jacques sébi qui
vous présentera notre dernière édition
demain
12h40 cinquantaine de midi 18h30 c'est
la vie et je vous retrouverai avec
plaisir demain à 20 heures
très bonne soirée sur antenne 2